[Music]
now scotland's a ruling snp
is in trouble on several fronts but it
doesn't
seem to dent nicholas sturgeon's
popularity at least
not so far she's still easily favored to
win scotland's may
elections however she is increasingly
assailed on all sides
from alex simon's claims that she was
part of a conspiracy
to do him down to scotland mp
joanna cherry who this week was fired
from a front bench position
uh also to criticism that the rollout of
the vaccine
north of the border is not going quite
as smoothly
as it is elsewhere in the uk to unrest
among the more
fundamental among her rank and file who
thinks she's not moving fast enough
for a second referendum so a lot there
building in but nicola sturgeon still
well
ahead in the polls and the only question
seeming to be
how well will she do come the hollywood
elections
in may let's discuss all this with the
spectators scotland editor alex massey
and spectator contributor and columnist
for the scottish
daily mail stephen daisler gentlemen
welcome to you both alex let me come
to you first it is right to say
but putting aside the impact that it's
having whether there's
much fallout there's much cut through
that
that the the government the scott gove
and nicolas sturgeon they
are a little bit beleaguered at the
moment yes i mean as you rightly suggest
there is a paradox at work here on the
one hand
the snp continued to register support
running at around 50
in all the opinion polls uh a level of
support that means the outcome
of may's hollywood elections assuming
they go ahead as planned and the first
minister is very keen that they do
uh the the uh the argument there uh is
will the snp win an overall majority or
will they
have to make do for what they currently
have which is a very strong minority
administration there where they
can often count on support from the
green party to ensure there is a
pro-independence majority
in the scottish parliament and yet as
you rightly say
uh there are any number of different
arguments
on multiple fronts taking place in the
smp at the moment as you
some of this is a small number of people
who are supporters of alex salmond who
feel that he's been stitched up by his
successor
um uh and the ongoing fallout from that
could yet cause significant difficulties
for nicola sturgeon
some of it is about the sort of
progressive or
what some people term a woke agenda on
gender recognition trans uh gender
rights
um uh and some of it is yes
well what how are we going to actually
force boris johnson
to hold a referendum on independence
that he that we think he might lose why
would he do that what's in it for him
and so all of these things contribute to
a situation which is remarkably febrile
in scottish politics even though the
actual outcome of the
election in may is pretty much not in
doubt
you know the snp are going to win the
question is how big
they win but within that there are any
number of discontents and this year's
opening
some of which put those short-term
problems for nicola sturgeon and the s
movement more generally
some of which could be quite serious in
the longer term
stephen is there any side even just at
the margins
that the the problems crowding in on the
first minister
are becoming corrosive or or is she
totally impervious to it
well i i think as um probably came
across quite well in alex's answer there
nicholas sturgeon is doing great in the
polls perhaps not so great in the
politics behind the polls
um in terms of her position she is in a
in a relatively strong position
given that although she doesn't have a
majority of hollywood she can rely on
the greens
um there is a great deal of support
uh behind her within the the
institutional party um
and much within the parliamentary party
she's also strengthened by the fact that
there isn't
really an immediate alternative and
the uh those who could um potentially
replace her
are actually people who are of the
suitable caliber i would say to be able
to step into that role
largely speaking um at least within
hollywood are
those who are sympathetic to her um
that is not to say that there aren't
problems there are very much problems
alex just went through them
i think that there is also a sense
that uh nicholas sturgeon has talked a
very good game
uh on many fronts she's talked a good
game on on forcing the the uk to allow a
second independence referendum
she talked a good game on kovard um and
now we're starting to see the
as the rubber hits the road moment um
where you see the
uh the uh we've transitioned from the
kind of
the rhetoric to the actual delivery and
whether it's on
a second independence referendum or it's
on the vaccine rollout where
uh scotland is is behind all of the
other nations
of the uk in rolling out the vaccine
um you are seeing that the delivery is
not matching up to the rhetoric
and so while her politically and
institutionally
um her position is is relatively strong
just now
and you can see the the figures
absolutely opening up
alex the the one thing if looking in
from the outside
the one thing that is surprising and did
i put it stronger than that it's kind of
jaw-dropping is that in the inquiry the
hamilton inquiry the
irish qc into whether or not nicola
sturgeon misled the house over this
over alex salmond and the process and
then the parliamentary inquiry into the
broader
areas of the salmon uh of the whole
salmon business
the amount of information that would
normally be in the public realm
is not in the is not allowed to be put
into the public realm
even the submissions of important
figures in the saga
which have been submitted to the
parliament are not allowed to publish
that information are people aware in
scotland
of how much is being suppressed
i think i mean you may raise a you know
number of excellent points there andrew
uh the answer the short answer to your
question is is no
um there is a widespread feeling uh that
although
the political and media class is very
interested in the nuts and bolts
of this issue the general public remains
fairly indifferent to it
that is partly because there is
obviously a sense i suppose that the
pandemic in its management is a rather
greater
matter than what happened between alex
salmond
and nicolas sturgeon a number of years
ago
and who said what what was said at what
meeting etc etc etc
all of which becomes very detailed very
quickly and very difficult to
to cut through um you know there still
isn't a
sound bite-sized charge against nicola
sturgeon
save that she has quite possibly
and possibly on multiple occasions at
best misled
the hollywood parliament and quite
possibly lied to it
whether that would i mean traditionally
obviously that would if if
confirmed if proved if accepted would
traditionally count as a
resignation matter but nicola sturgeon's
poll ratings and uh amongst the public
as a whole
not just snp supporters and it's
important i think to stress that
are such that i think quite a lot of
people could be persuaded that
ordinary circumstances do not apply just
now
and that she could conceivably survive a
scandal that would have destroyed
all her predecessors but you are
absolutely right also to suggest that
the way her government has handled this
inquiry having initially promised its
full cooperation
has persuaded an awful lot of people i
think that there must actually be
something more to it than meets the eye
because
a government that really had nothing to
hide uh first minister who really was
you know prepared to cooperate with the
inquiry to the fullest possible extent
simply wouldn't be behaving like this um
you know so it leads one to think that
there is something being covered up
now the question then becomes is it a
catalogue of
incompetence that is being covered up or
a catalogue of malice
that is being covered up or some uh
mixture of the two in proportions we
don't yet know
um but you know it is an excellent
example of how not um to run these
affairs i think if you're going to
to have a parliamentary inquiry and if
you are going to take credit
for your supposed candor and frankness
in establishing an inquiry into yourself
then you really do have to follow
through on that and cooperate with it
properly and that clearly has not been
the case in this instance
he said stephen one of the things that
does surprise us is if you take some key
submissions that this parliamentary
inquiry has asked from for crucial
witnesses
one from jeff aberdeen who was uh alex
simon's chief of staff and was involved
in
a particularly crucial meeting with
nicholas sturgeon
uh way back in 2018 and i i take it to
the
pilot's point that a lot of this is kind
of
uh almost ruatarian in its uh
information
in his complexity but the point is that
this
was this is a submission to a
parliamentary inquiry
but the parliamentary inquiry has
decided he's unable to publish that
evidence
i have been told that alex salmon's
submission to the public inquiry
that that may not be published either
and that indeed
he is worried about even testifying
before this inquiry
in case on some areas he's found to be
in contempt
of court i mean to be honest
he just wouldn't get away with that in
westminster
i think that that is a valid point um
it's important to separate out the
issues so um one of the issues is of
course the question of jigsaw
identification which is
you know i think we all agree very
important this is of the the women
who complained that eventually led to
uh alexander's trial uh and uh the
importance of protecting the anonymity
of the complainers
yes absolutely and so a good example of
that was
um the the committee has uh had to
slightly drag it out of the crown office
but he got access to
to whatsapp messages um which it has
uh said that the committee said it
wouldn't publish to to the general
public
um because it views them as a support
group of women who were supporting each
other
um and that that wouldn't be appropriate
obviously
um to publish that there is the issue of
jigsaw identification but if we put that
to one side
there is um a a broader question
about um how forthcoming um the the
scottish government has been willing to
be
um with documents and how um robust the
committee has been
in attempting to secure um some of those
um productions and there is a sense
that the uh that the committee is simply
and not uh robust enough it's not strong
enough in itself
to um to force the uh
the scottish government to produce some
of these um documents and
you know that is i think one of the
unfortunate
you know facts is that the committee has
um
although some has done some diligent
work and you know uh all credited to for
doing that
but there are some who wonder if this is
simply a committee that was
chosen as the forum for investigating
this matter because
it would not be able to get to the truth
because it would not be powerful enough
to uh to hold the scottish government to
account well it's certainly ironic
alex that this committee doesn't seem to
have the necessary teeth to do
a proper inquiry because i mean i was in
scotland when the parliament was set up
and the supporters of devolution their
great boast was
our our committees are going to have
real teeth you know we we won't have a
second chamber
uh in the scottish parliament instead we
will have
committees that will scrutinize
legislation before it goes
before the house will hold the
politicians to contempt
to to to account and yet here as you
have a situation where
you can turn up and testify under oath
it turns out what you said wasn't true
and instead of facing uh the force of
the law for testifying wrongly under
oath
you're asked to come back and put the
record straight and if you don't feel
like it
you say i can't be bothered i'm not
coming back i mean again in a
major select committee in westminster
that would just
never happen uh that that's true um
you know again lots of things going on
simultaneously
um the committee structure at hollyrood
is too weak i think there is a general
acceptance of that
at hollywood it is two week partly
because as well it is these committees
are staffed by people who are not
themselves
particularly capable uh it doesn't have
proper legal counsel
it hasn't got a proper legal counsel um
but yeah well indeed they're
insufficiently staffed as well and
resourced
um you know it is a major institutional
failing of the scottish parliament and
of devolution settlement if you like at
present
there are occasions when when committees
do do some better work i mean for
instance the
the scottish government's proposed hate
crime bill that is
proving extremely controversial as well
has essentially been gutted
um even before it's uh been put to the
the floor of the parliament and in part
that is because of the work of
of the the justice committee that has
been analyzing it but overall
yes you have a problem in scotland of an
over mighty executive
and an enfiebled legislature um and
uh that it that it that is then perhaps
also combined with as you
know well from your own experience um
and in freeboard scottish press that
lacks the resources sometimes to
to cover parliament properly and a
broadcast media in scotland
that has also is also much diminished
compared to
where it was a generation ago in terms
of uh the scrutiny
it is prepared to to apply to whoever
happens to be
in in power in edinburgh at the moment
obviously
that is the the smp and they've been in
power for 14 years which
you know i think one can make a
plausible argument is long enough
um and you see not not whether one
agrees with the snp or not per se
simply that after 14 years in government
if you have not achieved your
initial objectives it's extremely
unlikely that you are going to
um and all governments uh run out of
steam
of ideas and the ability the capacity to
reinvent themselves and i think
we're seeing a lot of that with nicola
sturgeon's government at the moment as
well
which accounts for some of the sort of
frustration and
this sort of curious sense again as we
got was as we were saying at the
beginning
where on the one hand scottish politics
is extremely stable
you know the snp first everyone else
nowhere and yet within that
there is an enormous amount of strife
and instability
uh and inside the snp and more generally
in scottish politics it is if you like a
sort of
caledonian anticipatory of our times
yes indeed stephen you your doc
crucial documents that should be in the
public domain being
massively redacted crucial submissions
to a
public inquiry not being published
the crown office seemingly using
jigsaw identification with in the
broadest possible interpretation
in ways that sometimes defy logic
to close down information becoming
public that they don't want
to become public if that was happening
in london i couldn't see the the the
london press
london media putting up with this is the
scottish media just too supine
well i i think that there is um first of
all
alex identified some of the important
structural issues you know scotland is
obviously it's a smaller country
we have um if us even proportionally we
probably have um
uh less in the way of a media landscape
um
we you know you could argue the the
media is
less adversarial i'm talking about
broadcast media here
um there is less of a there's there's no
sort of a robert peston or
uh laura kunzberg um sort of figure
who's
um uh you know it is seen as the thorn
in the side of the government of the day
whoever that is
um and also you know there is the the
point as i say as alex makes that the
um the scottish media just lacks a lot
of the resources
um you know it's not i know some people
think there's a you know some
conspiracy that the scottish press
doesn't want to to investigate the snp
that you know
it is much more the the fact that there
is just not this the the same bodies on
the ground that they're once where
and you know you know yourself from um
you know that the scottish
press and was once you know prided
itself on its robustness and you know
having armies of reporters
they could send in um you know not so
much now
i i think this is probably um
this is probably showing up the um the
real
trouble you get into when you don't have
a robust well-staffed well-funded
adversarial media and where you have a
government uh that
is in trouble in all sorts of fronts um
and yet you know on what is you know as
you see if this were happening in
westminster this would be uh
not only would be national news i i've
arguably international news
uh that is you know not happening in
scotland it is as alex and and you've
also alluded to it it's barely cutting
through with people
and so i think this does show what
happens when you know of a robust media
um and that is uh uh
i think that that highlights the problem
you know that we have several democratic
flaws in scotland the the parliament is
too weak
the the press is too weak and the the
government is not held to account enough
let me just finish on the uh the
post-election politics uh starting with
alex and then i'll come back to you
stephen
let's assume that nicola sturgeon wins
that's not a
dangerous assumption maybe she doesn't
get quite that overall majority but
she's still
clearly the winner of the election and
clearly the next first minister
up does she do you think alex does she
have a plan
in her mind a strategy over what to do
about a second referendum
no no is the the simple answer to that i
mean
you know the the argument will be that
she has the moral authority
to to press for a second direct second
independence referendum
that brexit is the kind of change in
circumstance that justifies
revisiting the national question six
seven eight years after
it was notionally decided in 2014. and
even if you're opposed to the smp's
plans i think one has to accept that
there is a certain moral force to that
argument
against that however it is only six
seven eight years since
uh the there was a referendum and it is
also i think morally plausible um and
morally just to argue that it is too
soon to reopen that question because
referendums have to have meaning
and that means the results have to be
given meaning otherwise you're into the
never-ending world
which is of little use to most people
and so you have a collision
between plausible arguments it seems to
me
and uh in the absence of consensus that
there should be
a referendum on independence and that
consensus remember
existed in 2012 which allowed the 2014
referendum to take place
in the in the absence of that consensus
it seems to me that it is very difficult
to proceed with one
even if you have the legal right to do
so um
even if the courts confirmed that you
could um because it has to be
a if uh a gold standard referendum to
use the smp's own phrase
and that means replicating most of the
conditions that applied in 2014
and as i say i think that one of the
chief ones of those is the consent of
those
who do not want independence you know
the unions
you could if unionists agreed that there
should be a referendum there would be no
problem
but you know we all have to live in the
scotland that happens
after it and so therefore the referendum
itself i think
has to take place at a time when there
is widespread acceptance and agreement
that it is a suitable moment for it
and we are still some way off that you
know the just say no
approach which the prime minister is
duty-bound to follow
is clearly subject to the laws of
diminishing returns because every year
that you move
away from 2014 is a year closer to a
time when it might be okay to revisit
the question
but for the time being it seems to me
there is just enough juice
remaining to be extracted from that
position and there is frankly very
little i think that nicola sturgeon
can do about that and concocting plans b
c d e f g all the way to z if necessary
and so
doesn't actually change that fundamental
dynamic
which is that there isn't at present a
way for her to force the referendum
and so we are then stuck in a kind of
waiting pattern
in which nationalists rather like mr
micawber are waiting for something to
turn up that will
bring them the referendum and unionists
for their part
are waiting for something to turn up
that will either shoot the referendum
fox
or if there is a referendum uh cause the
nationalists to you
to lose it um and so we're again in this
sort of febrile state in scottish
politics where everything is possible
but nothing ever changes all right final
brief thought on this
from you stephen before we move on uh
well i think that uh
i would largely agree that there is very
little nicola sturgeon can do the snp
has come out with this
so-called road map to a referendum and
the
um proposition in this is that they will
just simply if they win a majority in
may they'll bring forward a referendum
and essentially dare the uh the uk
government to try and stop them in the
courts if they if they
if they feel they can i think that's
more about ginning up
the national space ahead of the election
and there's very little
there's very little leeway here for the
snb the constitution is reserved and if
boris johnson doesn't want to give a
referendum if the uk parliament doesn't
want to give vic
doesn't want to give one it doesn't have
to give one all right jen's been plenty
to keep you busy north of the border
thank you for your time
today for joining us here on spectator
[Music]
tv
[Music]
you